in Minnesota this is just my God if you
have a frying pan hit yourself in the
head right now Minnesota lieutenant
governor Peggy Flanagan listened to her
defending sex changes for minors
because let's be clear
this is life affirming and life-saving
health care
when our children tell us who they are
it is our job as grown-ups to listen and
to believe them
that's what it means to be a good parent
you know that Meme from Billy Madison
everything that oh you got a frying pan
I don't know how you got to the kitchen
that quickly the size of a flat in
London these days I'll tell you
um everything she said there was
complete insane it's not affirming care
to chop someone's genitals off Peter
you've talked an awful lot about this go
ahead
yeah it's staggering and what's really
worrying is that this debate just
doesn't seem to be making any Headway I
mean how can anybody justify allowing
miners whose frontal lobes aren't even
fully formed yet to make life-changing
decisions about their bodies it's
absolutely astonishing and it it's proof
that mission creep can become really
really dangerous you know we're now at
the point where we're allowing miners to
make horrendous decisions without giving
them the information that they truly
need Studies have shown that most people
who identify as trans when they're
teenagers are actually just gay and they
grow out of that phase and they they are
so thankful that they didn't have any
surgery
um why would we be encouraging given
that day so why would we be encouraging
people to do the opposite to indulge in
something that they don't really know
anything about it's it's staggering and
it's a dereliction of Duties really I
think but for anybody who's who's got
children or young people in their lives
even if you fully acknowledge that the
the mental state of a trans person that
they TR you know that some percentage of
people genuine 100 percent believe they
are in the wrong body the idea that you
can alter your body and somehow your
problems are going to go away on the
other side after all of the money and
all of the surgeries and all of the
hormone therapy and all of those things
that you're going to look exactly the
way you want to look and be able to find
the partner who you know is just right
for you and all those things it's
probably a pipe dream in and of itself
but there are some sane voices on this
there was a tweet by Elon Musk that I
thought was quite this was in response
to the video of the Minnesota attorney
general that video that we showed you he
wrote not when their fed propaganda by
adults moreover every child goes through
an identity crisis before their
personality slash identity crystallizes
therefore we shouldn't allow severe
irreversible surgery or sterilizing
drugs that they may regret until at
least the age of 18. so Samantha that's
at least somewhat refreshing right we do
have some voices pushing back against
this stuff although as Peter said it
seems like it just keeps going and going
and going going
absolutely it is very refreshing to see
this and I'm glad that we have the
ability to share the truth on Twitter
again thank you Elon Musk for that
because now I am starting to see more
and more posts photos and videos of what
transition surgery really does look like
for young men and young women and it's
not a pretty thing at all if you look at
a double mastectomy and you look at a
young girl who recently had her breasts
chopped off it it looks very horrific it
looks like something we should not be
advocating for if you'd like more sane
takes on our insane World check out our
direct message clips playlist and if you
want to watch more full episodes of our
live round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell